مرحبا بعد التساؤلات الكثيره عن اسباب
تغيب النجمه ديانا حداد عن حفل تريو
الرياض واللي ضم العديد من النجمات
العربيات تقيم ديانا يوم السبت حفل لجمهور
الرياض ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياضي يشاركها
الغناء فيه مروه خوري والفنانه كارول
سماحه ديانه اللي اطلقت مؤخرا اغنيه احلى
كابل باللهجه المصريه من كلمات ضياء عشاء
وهلحان عمر خير وهي احدى اغنيه البوم
ديانا الجديد ولي يحمل اسمها واللي طرحت
منه الى الان اغنيه
وحشني شخص وعدت بانه اطلانتها في هذا
الحفل راح تكون على مود جمهور السعودي
تحديدا حيث شخبارك مجموعه من انجح اغنيتها
بينهم لادائها على المسرح ان شاء الله راح
يكون معكم تاريخ 14-1
بحفله من حفلات موسم رياض راح يكون في
مزيج بين القديم والجديد من اغنيتي واا
راح اقدم بعض الاغاني بطريقه مختلفه وان
شاء الله راح يكون في مفاجاه ضمن جدول احف
لكل الحضور
[موسيقى]
بخصوص حلقات الجزء التاسع عشر ما ينفعش ما
طاش وعلى اسم مخرج الجزء الجديد بعد رحيل
المخرج عبد الخالق الغانم وقع الاختيار
على محمد القفاص مخرجا للعمل وتحت اشراق
عبد الرحمن الزايد ورغم انتقادات الجمهور
لتاخير الكبير في هذه الاجراءات كون العمل
المرتقب في رمضان القادم الا انه تم
التاكيد على انه التصوير راح يبدا الاسبوع
القادم وما عرفنا في كواليس انه هو لغايه
وقت عمل الاجتماع لم يتم التوقيع مع اي
فنان على الاطلاق بعد الظهور في حلقات
الجزء الجديد من طاش والمفترض ان تكون
السلسله الدراميه متصله
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حكايه الناس اللي ولا
حاجه
لم نفسك
[موسيقى]
قائمه الافلام
في عام 2022 الا انه فيلم شلبي اللي اطلقه
كريم في موسم راس السنه من ايام لم يحضر
بنفس الاصداع او النجاح حيث يعتبر اراده
الفيلم ام متواضعا بينما لم تحقق اغنياته
انتشار كبير في حين ذهبت بعض الاراء
لمقترح انه لو تمت الوجه الفيلم للاطفال
لكن نجح بشكل اكبر خاصه من الجمهور
الاطفال احب الفيلم واغنيات جدا
عايز يعمل مسرحيه شعبيه
ثانيا الفيل من الناحيه البصريه والناحيه
الموسيقيه مبهج جدا الفيل مهدا الى روح
صلاح السقا رائد مسرح العرايس في مصر
الفيلم كان ايضا فرصه حلوه نتعرف اكثر على
الممثل حاتم صباحا زهره الكثير من المواهب
وقدم دور ممكن يمهل له ظهور اكثر مستقبلك
نفر نقيب المهن التمثيليه الدكتور اشرف
زكي كل ما تردد 24
الحشيش الاخيره واللي صدر فيها حكم بالسجن
السلام على ايقاف التنفيذ وغرام عشره الاف
جنيه لافته لانه الشروط القانونيه الخاصه
بشطب العضويه لا تنطبق على الفنانه
المصريه لان الحكم الصادر بحق علي يزال
قابله للاستئناف والنقد واكد الفنان اشرف
زكي انه لاصحه لما يتم تداوله منه شلبي
مشيرا لان النقابه لم تتاثر بالحكم الصادر
من محكمه جنايات القاهره لانه ليس نهائيا
من ظروف هذه الواقعه باعتبار ان المخدرات
التي ضربت معها غلبت من الخارج وكان مصرح
بتداولها خارج مصر ان ظروف الواقع ككل
تستوجب وقفه تنفيذ هذه العقوبه على ان لا
تعود المتهم الارتكبها مره اخرى لان هذا
حكم اذنك لا يجوز نقابه المهن التمثيليه
الان ان تتخذ اي اجراء همم ضد منه شلبي او
اي متهم لم يصير الحكم الصادر بشان الحكم
نهائيا يعني ايه حكم نهائي
يعني هي لازال امامها درجه اخرى من درجات
التقاضي باعتبارا للحكم الذي صدر بالايقاف
هو حكم بالاداء
[موسيقى]